in quantum mechanics we use a wave
function to describe everything there is
to know about a particle for example its
distribution and space the wave function
describes the wave nature of particles
squaring the wave function gives a
probability density or the likelihood of
finding the particles at any given point
a probability of zero would mean there
is no chance of the event happening and
a probability of one would mean it's
certain because the probability is
spread out over space the probability of
finding a particle at each point is
going to be a value between zero and one
if you add up all the probabilities what
you're doing is integrating the function
and the sum will be one because it is
certain that we will find the particles
somewhere along our distribution the
size starter is the complex conjugate of
the wave function and this whole term is
used to essentially square the wave
function but it is done this way because
the wave function might be a complex
number or contain the number I integral
quantities are common in quantum
mechanics you often want to find the sum
of probabilities over a certain range
and you can write it in a simplified way
this is Dirac notation on the left this
is the conjugate of our wave function
and on the right is our state this is
the state that the particle or whatever
else we're describing isn't if there are
multiple states which a particle can
exist in then we can write a mini
superposition of states
a and B that coefficients are the
amplitude of our wave function and
squaring them gives the probability of
that state Schrodinger's cat is a
thought experiment where the cat exists
in a quantum superposition of states
where the states are either alive or
dead because the cat's fate is linked to
the random decay of a radioactive
particle the coefficients in this case 1
over root 2 the same since there is
equal chance of the cat being either
alive or dead
squaring gives a value of 1/2 so if each
state has a probability of 1/2 these add
up to 1
as expected the cat has to be either
alive or dead it's certainly going to be
one of the two and there's no
probability of being otherwise